♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
THIS WEEK THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION REVEALED ITS
PROPOSAL TO OVERHAUL
AMERICA'S IMMIGRATION
SYSTEM.
THE PROPOSAL WOULD NOT BY
ITSELF BUILD THE OFTEN
PROMISED WALL ON OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER NOR WOULD IT
CUT CURRENT LEVELS OF
IMMIGRATION DESPITE THE FACT
THAT MOST AMERICANS WOULD
LIKE TO SEE THAT HAPPEN.
THE ONE BIG THING THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
WOULD DO IS GIVE PRIORITY TO
IMMIGRANTS WHO MIGHT
ACTUALLY HELP AMERICA,
SKILLED WORKERS WITH ENGLISH
PROFICIENCY.
IT'S HARD TO SEE AN ARGUMENT
AGAINST A SYSTEM LIKE THAT.
THERE ISN'T REALLY AN
ARGUMENT AGAINST THAT
SYSTEM.
FOR YEARS DEMOCRATS HAVE
ARGUED THAT IMMIGRANTS MAKE
VITAL ADDITIONS TO OUR
ECONOMY.
THEY ARE SMARTER THAN WE
ARE, THEY ARE HARDER WORKING
AND DO BETTER IN SCHOOL.
THEY FOUND MORE COMPANIES.
THE PRESIDENT HAS DECIDED TO
TAKE DEMOCRATS AT THEIR
WORD.
HE SAYS HE WANTS ALL OF
THOSE GOOD THINGS THAT
IMMIGRANTS BRING.
WATCH.
>> WE WANT IMMIGRANTS COMING
IN WE CHERISH THE OPEN DOOR
THAT WE WANT TO CREATE FOR
OUR COUNTRY, BECAUSE BIG
PROPORTION OF THOSE
IMMIGRANTS MUST COME IN
THROUGH MERIT AND SKILL.
>> Tucker: WELL MUCH THE
WORLD WOULD MOVE HERE IF
THEY COULD.
HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE.
SO WHY WOULDN'T WE PICK THE
ABSOLUTE BEST.
IMMIGRANTS WITH SKILLS AND
ENGLISH WOULD FIT IN BETTER
HERE.
THEIR KIDS WOULD DO BETTER
IN SCHOOL.
THEY WOULD BE MORE LIKELY TO
CONTRIBUTE TO SOCIAL
PROGRAMS INSTEAD OF DRAINING
THEM.
ARE DEMOCRATS REJOICING IN
THIS CHANGE?
OF COURSE NOT.
THEY ARE OUTRAGED.
HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI
SPOKE FOR THE PARTY WHEN SHE
SAID REALLY MERIT IS A BAD
WORD BECAUSE EVERYBODY HAS
MERIT.
>> I WANT TO JUST SAY
SOMETHING ABOUT THE WORD
THAT THEY USE MERIT.
IT IS REALLY A CONDESCENDING
WORD.
ARE THEY SAYING FAMILY IS
WITHOUT MERIT?
ARE THEY SAYING MOST OF THE
PEOPLE THAT HAVE EVER COME
TO THE UNITED STATES IN THE
HISTORY OF OUR COUNTRY ARE
WITHOUT MERIT BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE AN ENGINEERING
DEGREE?
CERTAINLY WE WANT TO ATTRACT
THE BEST IN OUR COUNTRY --
TO OUR COUNTRY AND THAT
INCLUDES MANY PEOPLE FROM
MANY PARTS OF SOCIETY.
>> Tucker: WHAT A SHAME WE
CAN'T STAFF THE DEMOCRATIC
CAUCUS IN THE CONGRESS USING
THE SAME CRITERIA THE
SPEAKER WOULD LIKE TO FILL
OUR COUNTRY.
WE WANT TO ATTRACT THE BEST
FROM MANY PARTS OF THE WORLD
SHE SAYS.
BUT, OF COURSE, BY THAT
PELOSI DOESN'T MEAN WHAT SHE
SAYS.
SHE MEANS JUST THE OPPOSITE.
BECAUSE WHAT EXACTLY IS BEST
ABOUT IMMIGRANTS WHO HAVE
CRIMINAL RECORDS OR MIDDLE
SCHOOL EDUCATIONS OR NO
ABILITY TO HOLD A JOB IN THE
ANSWER IS THERE IS NOTHING
BEST ABOUT THAT.
IMMIGRANTS LIKE THAT MIGHT
BE NICE PEOPLE MUCH MORE
LIKELY TO BURDEN THE UNITED
STATES THAN BENEFIT
ECONOMICALLY.
HARVARD DOESN'T ADMIT
STUDENTS THAT DON'T SPEAK
ENGLISH IT.
SAYS SO ON THEIR WEBSITE.
WHY SHOULD OUR COUNTRY.
THE LEFT DOESN'T WANT TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS LIKE THAT.
SHUT UP, REYES O. RACIST.
THEY DECLARE THE CURRENT
SYSTEM IS GREAT.
NO EVIDENCE NECESSARY.
WATCH THIS FORMER OBAMA
OFFICIAL MAKE HER FACT-FREE
CASE ON MSNBC YESTERDAY.
>> WHAT'S LEFT ON THIS IS
THE MEDIUM AND EVEN THE
LEAST SKILLED IMMIGRANT ALSO
CONTRIBUTE TO THE U.S.
ECONOMY.
THEY COME IN AND THEY DO
DIFFERENT THINGS FOR NATIVES
AND THEY ALLOW EVERYONE TO
SPECIALIZE MORE ON WHAT THEY
ARE DOING BEST.
THAT CONTRIBUTION OF THE
UNSKILLED IMMIGRANTS THAT I
THINK PEOPLE OVERLOOK WHEN
THEY REALLY PUSH THE
SO-CALLED MERIT BASED OR
WHAT'S CALLED IN OTHER
COUNTRIES THE POINT SYSTEM.
>> Tucker: UM-HUH.
SO WHAT PROFESSOR HUNT AND
SO MANY ON THE LEFT,
INCLUDING THE SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE, ARE ARGUING FOR IS A
FUTILE SYSTEM WHERE
FOREIGN-BORN WORKER BEES
TOIL TO SUPPORT A SMUG AND
PAMPERED MANAGERIAL CLASS OF
WHICH THEY, OF COURSE ARE
PART.
THERE IS NO OTHER
EXPLANATION FOR OUR CURRENT
POLICIES.
WE DON'T NEED MORE LOW
SKILLED WORKERS IN THE
UNITED STATES.
WE HAVE PLENTY OF LOW
SKILLED WORKERS.
THEIR UNEMPLOYMENT RATE IS
HIGHER THAN THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE.
THEIR RAGE GROWTH HAS BEEN
ABYSMAL FOR DECADES,
GENERATIONS.
SO HOW DID THOSE WORKERS
BENEFIT FROM HAVING MORE
COMPETITION?
OF COURSE, THEY DON'T.
HOW DOES THE COUNTRY BENEFIT
BY HAVING MORE LOW SKILLED
WORKERS WHEN TECHNOLOGICAL
CHANGES MAY SOON RENDER
MILLIONS OF THEM PERMANENTLY
JOBLESS IN THE ANSWER, OF
COURSE, IS THAT WE WON'T
BENEFIT.
BUT, FOR THE LEFT, WHETHER
THE COUNTRY BENEFITS IS NOT
THE POINT.
CONGRESSWOMAN ILHAN OMAR
HERSELF A SYMBOL OF
AMERICA'S FAILED IMMIGRATION
SYSTEM IF THERE EVER WAS
ONE.
SOMEONE WHO HATES THIS
COUNTRY COMING HERE AT
PUBLIC EXPENSE SPENT
YESTERDAY DEMANDING THE
ABOLITION OF ICE, THE
DECRIMINALIZATION OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION ITSELF AND AN
END TO ALL DEPORTATION
PROGRAMS.
SHE DEMANDS OPEN BORDERS,
THE UNLIMITED ARRIVAL OF
ANYONE WHO WANTS TO COME TO
AMERICA WHETHER THEY HAVE
ANYTHING TO CONTRIBUTE OR
NOT AND BY THE WAY YOU GET
TO PAY FOR IT.
AND IF YOU DON'T WANT TO,
YOU ARE A BIGOT.
WELL YOU KNOW WHAT THIS IS
REALLY ABOUT, OF COURSE.
IT'S NOT ABOUT CIVIL RIGHTS.
THAT'S A JOKE.
IT'S ABOUT MONEY AND POWER.
THEIR MONEY, THEIR POWER.
THE LEFT HAS A LINE WITH
BUSINESS INTEREST THAT
PROFIT FROM CHEAP OBEDIENT
WORKERS.
LOW SKILLED IMMIGRANTS HAVE
A HARDER TIME ASIMULATING
INTO THE AMERICAN
MAINSTREAM.
THEY STAY POOR AND LEARN
ENGLISH MORE SLOWLY REMAIN
ETHNIC UNDERCLASS MUCH MORE
LIKELY TO VOTE DEMOCRAT LONG
TERM THAT'S THE POINT
OBVIOUSLY.
SKILLED IMMIGRANT MIGHT
ASSIMILATE AND BECOME LESS
RELIABLE DEMOCRATIC VOTERS.
THEY MIGHT EVEN COMPETE WITH
THE CHILDREN OF OUR RULING
CLASS.
THAT'S NOT ALLOWED.